اعرب الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عن قلقه من
الاوضاع في اسرائيل وطالبه اللاعبين
بالتخلي عن التعديلات القضائيه واضاف انه
لا يعتزم تقديم دعوه وشيكا لبنيامين
نتنياهو لزياره واشنطن اما نتنياهو فاكد
متانه العلاقات مع واشنطن رغم وجود خلافات
وكان نتنياهو قال ردا على بايدن ان
اسرائيل دوله ذات السياده لا تقبل اي ضغوط
خارجيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه ما مغزى اعلان بايدن ان
اسرائيل لا تستطيع مواصله مسارها الحالي
ونفيه امكانيه دعوه نتنياهو لزياره واشنطن
قريبا وما خطه ادارته لتعديل المسار في
اسرائيل
وكيف نقرا تلميح نتنياهو بعض وزرائه لرفض
تصريحات بايدن بشان الازمه في اسرائيل
وتاكيدهم انها دوله ذات السياده ترفض
الضغط حتى من افضل الاصدقاء وما هي مالات
تصعيد حكومه نتنياهو مع اداره بايدن
وانعكاسات ذلك على علاقه واشنطن بتل ابيب
وعلى القضيه الفلسطينيه وبقيه قضايا
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
على خلفيه ازمه التعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل والتي بدت كعامل كعامل اخرج الى
العلم خلافا كان مكتوما بين الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وحكومه اليمين المتطرف
في اسرائيل بزعامه بنيامين نتنياهو على
وقع ذلك كله واصل بايدن تصريحاته بشان تلك
الازمه واعراب عن قلقه زام الت اليه
الاوضاع في اسرائيل واكد انه انها لا
تستطيع الاستمرار في هذا المسار ادى بايدن
حكومه رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الى التخلي عن مشروع التعديلات القضائيه
واضاف انه لا يعتزم دعوه نتنياهو لزياره
واشنطن في المدى القريب
وفي المقابل
نتنياهو الذي كان قد اكد ردا على تصريحات
سابقه لبايدن دعى فيها الى تسويه سريعه
لقضيه التعديلات القضائيه اكد ان اسرائيل
دوله مستقله ذات السياده وانها لا تقبل
الضغوط الخارجيه حتى من اقرب الاصدقاء وقد
وجه وزرائه وفق ديوانه بعدم التعليق على
تصريحات بايدن واكد بدوره متانه العلاقات
بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
كما تعلمون سبق للولايات المتحده واسرائيل
مرتا بخلافات عرضيه سابقه لكن واؤكد لكم
ان التحالف بين ديمقراطيه عظيمه
وديمقراطيه قويه وفخوره ومستقله مثل
اسرائيل في قلب الشرق الاوسط هو تحالف لا
يمكن زعزعته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الجزء الاول من هذه الحلقه من تل ابيب
الدكتور دان شفتان رئيس برنامج دراسات
الامن القوميه في جامعه حيفا وسينضم الينا
ضيوف اخرون لاحقا في هذا النقاش دان شفتان
استمعت الى مقاله الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن انه لا يعتزم قريبا دعوه نتنياهو
لزياره واشنطن هو امر غير مالوف في عمر اي
حكومه اسرائيليه وايضا تصريحه الخاص
بضروره ان تتراجع الحكومه الاسرائيليه عن
مسار التعديلات القضائيه كيف تنظر الى هذه
التصريحات والمواقف الامريكيه
في الحقيقه نحن نشهد ازمه حقيقيه في
الداخل الاسرائيلي هي ازمه غير مسبوقه في
داخل اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تود ان تضغط على نتنياهو من اجل التوصل
الى حل وسط ولكن الضغط على نتنياهو من
الداخل الاسرائيلي هو قوي للغايه بشكل ان
الضغط الامريكي يمكن ان يساعد قليلا ولكن
ليس بشكل كبير الاسرائيليون يتعينوا عليهم
ان يتوصلوا الى حلول وحلول وسط فيما بينهم
وهذا ما سيحصل في نهايه المطاف في نفس
الوقت هناك مساء مرتبطه بالسياسات
الداخليه ان بايدن يتعين عليه ان يخاطب
الحزب الديمقراطي وعدد كبير من الامريكيين
لديهم بواعث قلق حقيقيه بما في ذلك اليهود
في الولايات المتحده ونتنياهو
يتحدث ويخاطب الجمهور الداخلي بانه لا
يخضع للضغط الامريكي ولكن التحالف
الاستراتيجي بين البلدين قوي وقائم ويعبر
الجانبان عن ذلك نحن نتحدث عن علاقه قويه
استراتيجيه بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
والمصالح المشتركه قويه للغايه حتى مع هذه
التطورات المؤسفه وهي مؤسفه بالفعل لا
اعتقد انها سوف تؤثر بشكل كبير لفتره ضمن
الناس ان العلاقه بين امريكا واسرائيل
تراجعت الاعداء ظنوا ذلك ولكننا نتحدث عن
مساله مؤقته ولكن عندما يحين الامر ان
نتحدث بالمسائل الجديه بما في ذلك ايران
وهي المساله الاهم المصالح المشتركه بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
التي سوف تضغط كان هناك سنتحدث هنا اسمح
لي للمقاطعه نحن لا نتحدث هنا عن العلاقات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه نحن نتحدث عن علاقه
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه بالحكومه
الحاليه التي يوجد فيها وزراء ترى
الولايات المتحده انهم غير لا نافعين لا
لاسرائيل ولا لتحالف امريكا مع اسرائيل
ولا للقضايا التي تريد اسرائيل وامريكا ان
تعالجها في المنطقه حينما يتحدثون عن
وزراء يقولون مثلا لا بد من اثباتت مدينه
باكملها او بلده باكملها او ان فلسطين لم
يكن بها شعب فلسطيني هذه تصريحات ترفضتها
الاداره الامريكيه هل العلاقه بين الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه والحكومه الحاليه تسير
في الاتجاه الصحيح
في الحقيقه يمكن ان تكون العلاقه افضل هذه
تصريحات مؤسفه وخصوصا من قبل وهو اعتذر
عنها هي اثارت سخطه الولايات المتحده وعدد
كبير من الاسرائيليين يعرف الناس ما حصل
هل لدينا مشكله الان نعم هل هذه المشكله
تقود اساس واسس العلاقات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه بكل تاكيد لا الوزراء الذين
يتحدثون عن هذا الامر هم يخاطبون المجتمع
الاسرائيلي داخليا ولكن لا تاثير لذلك على
العلاقات بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي سوف تستمر وهي قائمه على
القيم والمصالح في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اذا
ما ارادت
قيم التي تتحدث عنها الولايات المتحده منذ
فوز حكومه اليمين هذه اليمين المتطرفه
ترى ان اسرائيل
تسير في اتجاه خطر على ديمقراطيتها وفق
التعبير الامريكي
هل هل ايضا تصريحات تصريحات من غير الذي
قال انه على الولايات المتحده ان تدرك ان
اسرائيل ليست النجمه النجمه في العالم
الامريكي وان على الولايات المتحده ان
تفهم ذلك هل هذه التصريحات تنم فعلا عن ان
العلاقات هذه الاسرائيليه الامريكيه هي
امر مسلم به ام انها قيد مراجعه ايضا من
جانب الاسرائيليين وحتى من جانب
الامريكيين
كلا لا اعتقد انها تخدع لمراجعه ان
الحكومه
ذهبت بعيدا للغايه ان مقترحات الحكومه
كانت متطرفه وغير مبرره والحقيقه هي اننا
بحاجه الى التوصل الى حل وسط وهذا ما يتم
التناقش بشانه ولكن يجب ان نتنبه الى
المواجهات الاكثر حده في اسرائيل اليوم
حول مساله مهمه للغايه وهذا الامر يتم من
خلال السبل الديمقراطيه لا الحكومه ولا
المتظاهرين يتوقعون ان يكون هناك خروج او
اي خروج عن الاطر الديمقراطيه وربما هذا
اكبر امتحان للديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه
والديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه تبرز باحلى حله
في وجه هذا الاختبار نحن نتحدث عن خطاب
موجه الى الداخل الاسرائيلي يجب التوصل
الى حل الديمقراطي الحكومه بدات باجراءات
متطرفه المعارضه حشدت الراي العام ضد هذه
الاجراءات والطرفان دخل بخطوات ديمقراطيه
والان يتفاوضان بشان حلول هذه هي الطريقه
التي تعمل الديمقراطيه من خلالها هذه
السبل الطبيعيه في نظام في فرنسا على سبيل
يعني قبل ان نذهب الى فرنسا ننوه الى
مجموعه من الاخبار العاجله التي وردت ونحن
على الهواء مباشره وتوضح المسار الذي تسير
فيه تفاعلات علاقه اداره بايدن بحكومه
نتنياهو موقع ولا الاسرائيلي نقل عن مصادر
الرسميه اسرائيليه قال ان بايدن طالب
نتنياهو بلهجه قاسيه بالتراجع فورا على
التعديلات القضائيه موقع ولا الاسرائيلي
عن المصادر الرسميه الاسرائيليه يقول ان
بايدن عبر في رساله نتنياهو نقلها السفير
الامريكي عن الغضب من اقاله وزير الدفاع
وان بايدن درس بالفعل خيارات عده للضغط
على نتنياهو قبل ان يلجا الاخير نتنياهو
الى تجميد التعديلات القضائيه موقع اكسيس
ايضا الامريكي قال وذلك نقضي عن مساعدين
لنتنياهو قال ان الرئيس الوزراء لا يرغب
في حدوث ازمه مع اداره بايدن ومصادر
للجزيره قالت ان المشرعين الديمقراطيين
يدعون الى ضمان عدم استخدام اسرائيل اسلحه
امريكيه في انتهاكات حقوقيه
والمصادر نفسها تقول الجزيره ان المشرعين
الديمقراطيين ينمون الطلبه من بعض
المراجعه كيفيه استخدام اسرائيل للاسلحه
الامريكيه
كل هذا سيد دان شفتان الا يعبر عن ازمه
حقيقيه بين اداره بايدن واداره وحكومه
نتنياهو ازمه حقيقيه قد لا تنتهي اذا
استمر مسار الحكومه الحاليه
اعيدوا عليه
كل هذه الاخبار
الا تؤشر على ان هنالك ازمه حقيقيه بين
حكومه نتنياهو الحاليه والاداره الامريكيه
اذا استمرت حكومه نتنياهو في هذه المسارات
التي تسير فيها
حسنا
هناك ازمه محدوده ولكنها ليست ازمه بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده هناك توتر كبير
ويعبر عنه بطرق بعض هذه الطرق غير مسبوقه
ولكن العلاقات بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده لا تشهد ازمه كان هناك توتر مماثل
في السابق وسوف يمر هذا التوتر اسرائيل لا
تزال الحليف الاهم للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في المنطقه القيم المشتركه بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل لا تزال قائمه
الامريكيون لديهم مشاكل مرتبطه
بدمقراطيتهم هم
ونعود الى اداره ترامب وما عبر عنه
الديمقراطيات فيها مشاكل وديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه فيها مشاكل النقطه الاهم هي
ان الاسرائيليين يعالجون هذه المشاكل بطرق
الديمقراطيه الجانبان يتفاوضان بشان حلي
وسط هذه هي السبل الديمقراطيه شكرا جزيلا
لك من تل ابيب رئيس برنامج دراسات الامن
القومي في جامعه حيفا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
انتهى وقتنا للاسف
معنى من واشنطن ارحب بضيفي الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه وايضا تشارلز الدبلوماسي
والامريكي السابق في اسرائيل وابدا بك
دكتور خليل العناني ومغزى التصريحات
الاسرائيليه حينما يتحدث بن الخير عن ان
اسرائيل ليست نجمه في العالم الامريكي
وعلى الولايات المتحده ان تدرك ان اسرائيل
قادره على الدفاع عن نفسها حينما يتحدث
نتنياهو بلهجه تقارب ان اسرائيل لا تقبل
الضيم للرئيس الامريكي ويقول له ان
اسرائيل دوله مستقله ذات سياده ولا تقبل
الضغط الخارجي من اقرب الاصدقاء كيف تقرا
انت هذه اللهجه صحيح لهجه بايدن واضحه
وغير معوده لكن ايضا الرد الاسرائيلي
انا اعتقد جزء من رد الاسرائيلي متعلق
بالداخل الاسرائيلي هناك محاوله مستمره من
نتنياهو لمغازله اليمين المطرف الفاشف في
اسرائيل الذي جاء به للسلطه في اطار صفقه
المعرفه جميعا وهي محاوله القيام بهذه
التعادلات القضائيه من اجل عدم
ذهابه الى المحكمه بطعم الفساد في نفس
الوقت نفسه يحمل الاجند فشام متطرفه يغازل
بها اليمين الاسرائيلي مضطرف وبالتاليات
هي بشكل اخر لاستهلاك الداخلي لكن بشكل
بشكل عام من الصعب بجد التوقع ان يتمادوا
في هذه المساله لانه هناك مخاطر من ان
تنطلق العلاقه مع امريكا الى ازمه قد تكون
غير مسبوقه نحن الان توتر شديد ربما في
بدايات ازمه لوح في الافق لكن بشكل عام
هناك حرص على ما يبدو من التنميه وشخصيا
الذي يعتبر لحد بعيد يعني مقارنه بالاخرين
في الحكومه حريص على هذه العلاقه وراينا
تصريحات قبل قليل في مؤتمر الديمقراطيه
باعتباره يحاول ان يهدد فيها الاوضاع من
بعد تصريحات في البدايه عندما تحدث عن لا
يقبل الضغوط او املاءات من الخارج حتى وان
كان ح امريكا وبالتالي هناك تصريحات خاصه
بالداخل الاسرائيلي لكن ايضا هناك حرص
بشكل بخري على عدم انزلاق الوضع الحالي
لازمه قد تؤدي الى فقدان اهم محاليف
بالفعل الاسرائيلي في المنطقه العربيه
نعلم جميعا استاذين انه امريكا تقدم على
الاقل 3.5 مليار دولار سنويا مساعدات
عسكريه لاسرائيل بالاضافه كمان الى 500
مليون فيما يتعلق بنظام الدفاع الصاروخي
نعلم ايضا انه امريكا تقدم غطاء
الدبلوماسي وسياسي وقانوني لاسرائيل فيما
يتعلق بانتهاكتها في الارض الفلسطينيه
وايضا هناك دعم افريقي محدود فيما يتعلق
بمساله التطبيع مع الدول العربيه وفي ايضا
الموقف من ايران وبالتالي من الصعب تخيل
ان هناك تضحيه بكل هذه المكاسب من اجل بعض
قضاء الداخليه في تصريح حتى ان كانت تتعلق
بمستقبل السياسي نفسه
على تويتر ان هنالك
ان ان بعض المتظاهرين يتلقون
اموالا من الولايات المتحده
مما اضطر السفير الامريكي في تل ابيب
السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل الى ان يخرج
ويكذب هذه الادعاءات ويقول انها ادعاءات
سخيفه
اللغه المستخدمه برايك تؤشر على اي مرحله
وصلت اليها العلاقات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه
نعم اعتقد ان هذه الكلمات التي سمعناها
بالتاكيد ليست مناسبه وهذا يعكس
الازمه
والمستوى الازمه التي وصلت اليه العلاقه
ما بين الطرفين الرئيس بايدن بين جانبه
ايضا احيانا يتحدث بطريقه لا يقصد فيها ما
قال لكن اتصور ان ما وصل الى الاسرائيليين
لم يصل بطريقه المطلوبه ولكن
بالعمومه هذا يعكس
التوتر الموجود الان ما بين الطرفين اعتقد
ان
العلاقه الان اصبحت اكثر تعقيدا هذا قد
يؤثر حتى على الخطط الامريكيه
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
وهل الولايات المتحده دكتور تشارلز ستقف
مكتوفه الايدي ازاء ما يحدث في اسرائيل
الولايات المتحده معروف انها ساعدت وتساعد
في احداث تغييرات او تبني تيارات في دول
متعدده حدث ذلك في اوروبا الشرقيه حدث في
الربيع العربي
الا يمكن ان يحدث ايضا في اسرائيل هل يمكن
ان تكون هنالك بالفعل ايادي امريكيه فيما
يتعلق بالقوه المعارضه للحكومه الحاليه
التي لا تحبها اداره
الاداره الراهنه
ستحاول ان تكون حذره كي لا ترجح كافه طرف
على اخر في هذه الازمه الراهنه في اسرائيل
رئيس الامريكي
واعيه بما يحدث وهو يدعم بشكل علني
توجه نحو توافق الديمقراطي في اسرائيل
والدعم اي طرف اتجاهها ضد طرف حاره قد
يؤثر على العلاقه وقد يا الزم العلاقه
اكثر الان اسرائيل في ازمه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لن تقول ان هذا الطرف
له الحق والطرف الاخر على خطا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ستحاول ان تبقى
الطرف على خطا قال ان الحكومه الحاليه لا
يمكن ان تسير في هذا المسار اذا الاداره
الامريكيه تدخلت
نعم نعم هو قال ذلك لذلك اقول
انا الرئيس بايدن كان ربما غير موفقه في
اختيار الكلمات والعبارات لكن
رئيس بايدن لا يقول اكثر من ذلك
وفي تصور الرئيس الامريكي الان يركز على
دعم المسار الديمقراطي في اسرائيل وان
تاخذ هذه القضيه مسار الديمقراطي الان
طبعا الاداره الامريكيه ستكون مرتاحه
عندما تمكنت الاغلبيه في اسرائيل لم تتفق
على اي شيء تريده وهذا طبعا سيخرج الازمه
دكتور خليل العناني هل الضغط الامريكي
يتوقف عندما ذكرناه من موقع اكسس ام ان
هنالك طرق اخرى يمكن للاداره الامريكيه ان
تمارس بها الضغط على الحكومه الحاليه فيما
يتعلق لا سيما فيما يتعلق ايضا بملفات
المنطقه ملف
الضفه الغربيه والتصعيد فيها وملفات اخرى
لابد ان نفرق بين مواقف الاداره الامريكيه
مواقف المشرعين الديمقرا الجمهوريه بشكل
عام في مرسي فيما يتعلق بالاداره منذ
اليوم الاول هذه الحكومه هناك تحذيرات
كبيره جدا من عدم اتخاذ اي اجراءات قد
تؤدي الى توتر الوضع في فلسطين وراينا
زيارات متعدده لمسؤولين امريكيين على
راسهم وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الدفاع
وكذلك رئيس الجهاز المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه وكذلك مستغرب الامريكي من خلال
الاشاره الماضيه من اجل ارسال رساله واضحه
ليصلي بانه ليس هناك امكانيه للتقبل
المضي قدما فيما تعلق بالانتهاك الحقوق
الفلسطينيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان
وما الى ذلك ايضا قبل حوالي اسبوع من الان
عندما مر الكنيست قرار بالغاء قانون فك
الارتباط الذي يقرر عام 2005 والذي كان
يعني يشير الى فتره مات مع غاز وكذلك فك
تفكيك بعض المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه راينا هناك استدعاء لاول
مره على على 20 سنه استدعاء للسفير
الامريكي لسفير الاسرائيلي في امريكا
ابلاغه احتجاج امريكا على هذه الاجراءات
الاحاديه من جانب اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك
ضغط على الاقل من ناحيه الخطاب ومن ناحيه
المواقف السياسيه والدبلوماسيه هل الامر
يتطور الا ضغط اقتصادي او ضغط عسكري صعب
نتوقع ذلك
كان داخل الاداره الامريكيه
داعم بنفس الدرجه لانه هنالك
تملم ايضا في اوساط اليهود الامريكيين من
حكومه
هذا صحيح لحد بعيد هناك تصريحات وراينا
اليوم قال يا استاذ زين لتوماس فريدمان
وهي يعتبر من اهم الداعمين لاسرائيلي تحدث
فيه عن مخاطر التعاطي مع مع نت شخص غير
عقلاني وناصح اداره بايدن بعد متواصل معه
والتواصل مع الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن رغم
ذلك الامر الى مسائل المتعلقه بالامن
متعلقه بالتعاون العسكري من الصعب توقع
حدوث ازمه هذا الاطار كما قبل قليل هناك
فرق بين التعاطي مع حكومه نتنياهو وبين
الامن الاسرائيلي او حرص امريكا على امن
اسرائيل هناك دعم امريكي غير محدود عسكري
واستراتيجي لكن قد الامر قد يتعلق يتعلق
بما يتعلق بحاجتين الحاجه الاولانيه
بالموقف من التطبيع مع الدول العربيه كما
نعلم جميعا هناك سعي حثيث من من نتنياهو
من اجل التطبيع خاصه مع السعوديه ويعتبر
ذلك بالنسبه له انجاز في نفس الوقت هناك
محاوله للنجم ايران عسكريا قد يقوم بتقوم
اداره بيض باستخدام هذا هذين الامرين من
اجل كبح
جماعها لعدم قراءه تعداد قضائيه نعم في
اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور خليل العناني
للعلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه من
واشنطن ضيفنا من واشنطن ايضا الدكتور
تشارلز دان الدبلوماسيه والامريكي السابق
في اسرائيل
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]